the difference is that a robot piano
tomato sec-arembault it has an
industrial function so it must not be
aesthetic the automaton is precisely
it is poetry it is magic it is to
tell the story  completely
different
it's an animated sculpture it's a
stage it's a magic object
mechanics from a very young age after
I discovered automatons where there is
the artistic aspect of mechanics and
at the same time of sculpture and
that's what I liked from the start
he is the oldest known automata  good
already some time to help agip his people and then at the
end of the 18th century are really
developing very complex automatons
for for the time I had a little bit of
an obsession with being able to do
things as complex as what was
done at the end of the  eighteenth century we
always send to the four corners of the
world to make  our tomatoes there are a lot
of there are a lot of trades there is already
the sculpture to make you the shape the
character called there is the animation of
the head the eyes of the eyelids there are the
clothes there is the cabinetmaking
it is true that it does  a lot
of recent professions that we don't do it
we spent perhaps more than three years
on this automaton the aesthetics it goes
relatively quickly
but it's above all how we are going to do
that how to obtain such a movement
what is what  going to do that as soon as we have
the time and that takes quite a long time to perfect
[Music]
it's true that I have an attraction
for automatons insofar as we can
create new things for
me it's  not just automatons it's
really about developing the profession
there's no real limit we can
really always continue to
discover other things
we can always go further
[Music]